welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm finally joined by Steve guest that's
definitely my fault that's taken so long
and Steve guest is Brahmi by background
has been recruiting for 14 years in the
construction and property market has
always been a poem recruiter has built
desks and businesses from scratch has
mentored recruiters from rookies to
successful billers and more recently if
you're not connected with Steven linked
him then you should but you will
definitely be seeing him talking about
the book that he's written and he's the
author of the best-selling recruitment
book called top biller
which I'd like to think a lot of people
that listen to this podcast aspire to be
Steve so I'm excited to uncover the
Steve journey and talk about what makes
a top Billa Billa that's it I mean if
you're not in recruitment to become a
top performing sales person what are you
doing definitely I think yeah it's been
spoken about quite a bit in this podcast
about like you 100% should be aiming for
the top like why wouldn't you right so
where I always like to start on this
podcast I guess just for everyone
listening yes we are going to talk about
how Steve is surviving today in the
current climate we are going to talk
about why Steve write the book and sort
of the the key messages in that book
that a lot of the lot of you guys
listening can benefit from but like we
always do on this podcast and we're
gonna dive into sort of Steve's journey
and sort of how he's got to where he's
got to today so where I always like to
start on this podcast Steve is how did
Steve guest of Birmingham and for the
weather recruitment how did that happen
so a bit of a strange one really so I I
started out as a strategic commodity
buyer negotiating multi-million pound
framework contract for seven Trent water
okay and enjoyed the role was reasonably
good at it
and my wife was working as a maid
that's trades temp consultant for haze
yeah and I was dealing with these
contracts negotiating good levels of
savings getting Pat's on the back and
handed the next contract yeah and
sitting there thinking is is that all I
get
do an idea bonus or some sort of
commission or sharing the same mmm and
my wife was doing exceptionally well as
a temp consultant and obviously I've
seen her levels of earnings and thinking
yeah I could do me there I could do me
the bit of that yeah so I thought
logical process would be I went to have
an interview Hayes perching in supply
I'm doing the qualified buyer
I thought purchasing for procure sorry
recruiting for procurement staff and
good mentor would be the way to go yeah
first interview went really well
ops director said I've got on really
well wanting me to play in his father
side football team at my second
interview this which was the following
week so I walked out skipping all the
way home thinking yet now that went for
my second interview and I was told there
wasn't sales enough wasn't confident
enough didn't come across the right way
and didn't really fit the consultant
profile that they were looking for so
obviously really kind of gutted to be
honest wasn't used to being rejected
certainly at interview stage it never
happened to me before
yeah walked out in Birmingham into the
street and across the street
you've got house construction and
property so walked over there and
basically said look I've been for needs
of your age virgin supply I didn't think
I was quite the character they were
looking for you take me on and I'll
prove every single day on here that
they've made a mistake and that was
really it was completely my fuel to do
well and I did prove them wrong or is
the fastest trainee to get promoted the
fastest training - consultant consultant
to senior I still hold the regional
records for burn placements and burn
Billings as far as I'm aware that was
set back in 2007 I used to drop emails
back to the director after just saying
what Awards look what you could have had
so yeah that was probably the starlet's
love adoptions so I guess let's just
frame it up for everyone listening in
terms of sort of the the Steve journey
to date so join Hayes obviously huge
huge brand and recruitment big business
how long did you work there for I was at
Hayes for it probably just short of a
couple of years yeah two to three years
or he owes bet two years yeah I left to
set up a new office in region for
fast-track in the middle of 2008 yeah
and joined join ties in 2006 so it was a
short term I owe a lot to Hayes don't
get me wrong Hayes have impeccable
training ever oh it's awesome and any I
wouldn't be the consultant I am today if
I had spot on so so T is there then
files tried to open up a brand new
office yeah and and then just frame out
everyone listening so there and then
you've worked at the fast track for or
did work for fast track yeah no I worked
with fast track up until September of
last year so
open the Birman 2008 I opened an office
for them in 2015 based in Manchester
yeah
across the two regions I managed
mentored about 19 consultants at Hight's
okay queried to a sales turnover 7
million cost these new offices yeah
ok and then and then more recently just
to help me out and for people listen and
you've and that you're now self-employed
I went self-employed 2011 because I
wanted to have other areas that for me
to personally grow wants to do other
things yeah so we came to an agreement
where I could contract back to
fast-track and still work with them but
I had other things going on in the
background I want you to explore and do
so being self-employed is 2011 yeah my
wife when I moved to fast-track moved to
one of our competitors and we did it
with actually yeah we've actually
competed for 12 of the 14 years I think
oh that's mad yeah no pillow talk say do
you know what we've I'm really pleased
with the way we've managed that I mean
with my wife and I we've been together
20 years this year we know each other
really well and we are both very
ambitious and on the same page and so
yes 2011 went self-employed Emma joined
my business in 2016 after our second
child was born rather than her go back
to where she worked
yeah after maternity she came and joined
SES consultancy services to help grow
the brand in the business so and that
and that's we've been doing it and then
that's you now for to yeah so small
September last year I ended the contract
with fast-track okay cool yes it was
going down a different path and it it
wasn't where I wanted to be and I wanted
to go off and kind of explore other
avenues and so my actual view was
finished contracted fast-track and
actually just go back to day-to-day
recruiting yeah I really enjoyed the
permanent construction market as I say
I've done it
for 14 years great relationships I just
wanted probably six months where it's
just me I've got to max eBay it's you
know I've got a kick up the backside and
actually I just wanted to get back to
recruiting completely and 100% of my
time
yeah and that's what you've been doing
since pretty much started this year then
yeah it's so September I said I managed
about three months working from home
yeah and we've got two boys and I didn't
realize how short a school day was until
I said I fish at home and I walked in at
three o'clock shouting screaming so yeah
and then we leased an office in February
like a two-man office ran by us also and
obviously then current situation up so
we I've got about five weeks in okay so
I'm really excited to sort of unpack
this and then the final thing just to
help me sort of context as well so you
said obviously yeah part of this sort of
decision was you wanted to get back to
recruiting beating and tools as you were
but sort of that whilst that was a long
period at fast track was the majority of
time did you sort of recruit still or
yes okay see you well I've been feeling
consultant for for the whole time like a
coaching management responsibilities
obviously just crept up but your
Billings but still had to be done
basically exactly I still had my yearly
target I still expected and wanted to be
at the top of there yeah regardless of
managing and having different regions
okay cool perfect so that's great and
it's great to sort of get an insight
into sort of the journey until now so I
guess first thing that I would just love
to get your thoughts on obviously spoken
about Hays and how much of a sort of
grounding and I get a platform it it
gave you yeah yes I'm always interested
to hear people's forwards onto you you
speak to a lot of consultants now learn
from that you're doing what what would
sort of your advice be to people who are
maybe thinking about moving job or
wanted to go into recruitment or
thinking about should they join a big
business like Hays and obviously things
have probably changed since you've been
there
I guess what what would you say are the
biggest positives to joining a big
corporate like Hayes or Michael Page or
things like that I guess what just first
time that I'm always let's get people's
for us what do you think I'm the mayor
I'm in the huge positives for me for
working at Hays where the training was
impeccable and Hays being the big global
PLC that they are are very clued up on
numbers ratios expectations what levels
it takes to achieve the financial end
product that you're obviously going into
work overdue yeah so they're excellent
of that if you can work so their numbers
generally you are going to be a
reasonably successful person if you get
through all of their training you should
be an all-rounded individual that
understands all the facets within being
an agreement consultant that makes you
successful some of the big positives
with the likes of Hays you don't have to
necessarily market you as a personal
brand you've got such a big brand behind
you I had clients that just use Hays
because they were Hays you know those
question was that how much does that
actually help yes I mean the turnover of
staff within the cream you and I both
know he's he's high yeah people move on
every six to eight months generally
across markets and sectors so with
clients that say I always use Hays the
thought process there is yeah but you
speak to a different person probably
twice a year yeah but you still come
back in new hides and then William
because they're a market leader so I
would quite happily sit on my desk I'd
make my calls I do my activity but I
would still get calls come in from
companies I'd never spoke to or heard of
that would ring because their Hays and
they'd get passed to me because I was
the consultant that looked at the
surveys
yeah so there is a helping hand there
because the brand is so strong mmm the
downside to it is it's restricted oh I
found it restrictive anyway and because
you're in Groening such a corporate
structure you almost have to toe the
corporate line mmm so the
entrepreneurial side of me was always
squashed
and actually you have to go along with
the process okay obviously you can
benefit from that but you can also find
stuff a little bit yeah that hasn't put
I would be the same and I've found that
in where well I came unstuck a few times
because I would want to try and do
things even as a top performing
consultant in the office and one that
was highly regarded if I wanted to do
something different I mean back in the
day I wasn't allowed a company mobile
how ridiculous is that I wanted so I can
make the calls at home I want to be able
to log on to the database at home
because I want to continue working after
the offices shut I wasn't able to do
that because that to protect what they
had I mean it may well have chained I'm
sure it has chair turning the corner
change how I'm and then just quickly
before we move on how much of an
influence did it have on you early on
with in terms of the type of people that
you got access to I think what I'm
always interested in I joined a small
bits of my my boss that I work for he
was ex Hayes and sort of climbed up the
ranks and got to director level and was
there for over a decade right so I get
and then when I joined his business it
was a small business there was eight of
us when I joined and I get direct access
to the people in my four walls right
glad to brilliant people in there but it
was eight people right so I guess what
I'm always interested to hear and were
so like how yeah how much of an
influence or impact did it have on you
do you think in terms of the type of
people you've got access to or I think
at the time I suppose I was I was still
learning and I was extremely selfish
with my time and why I did it does open
doors certainly does give you access
because people within Hayes there are
people that have been there years and
years and years and they've placed the
people that are now CEOs managing
directors anything else and that opened
doors because they knew the directors
that went before you yeah and if I'm
balanced if I'm balancing that full
process with opening a new brand and new
region for a business that nobody's
heard of and you're purely relying on
your personal brand to get me through
the door the first 12 18 months of doing
that
despite the fact it was in recession was
still really difficult mmm whereas
perhaps you'd take for granted what
Hayes offered because it was just there
almost on the plate yeah okay
interesting
um right so then obviously started
obviously joined fast-tracked during the
the crash yeah so you've got a habit of
starting new things then when [ __ ] goes
bad yeah I mean thinking back great
decision at the time I mean I was
questioning whether it was there was
some really dark days what would what
did just describe sort of the actual
your world at that point like was it
literally obviously did well at Hayes
great Billa
hit records blah blah blah right okay
well I've got the confidence to stop a
brand new desk
new part of this business I'm gonna
smash it my way it comes and then you
literally call him people they're going
to Steve I've got nothing for you mate
like yeah the market just stopped
content hole it was it was days of
making or doing double the activity for
actually no return whatsoever yeah
except for really tough discussion
discussions obviously didn't in
construction it can be nice colorful
language at times straight talking so it
was it was a huge fall from grace to be
honest because I walked in thinking it
was all going to be great if you if it
paints a picture in terms of my logic I
Hays I had West Midlands construction
commercial perm letters a 2n in the
alphabet with in a post coated area
there's a jobs outside of that area I
passed the different offices different
consultants if it was freelance it went
to someone else it was very very small
Anish yep to say of the cell to go to
fast-track was there was no one else
doing what I did in the company hmm
so I had the whole country yeah don't
you think that's kind enough to pass the
phone you sit there and you think okay
well if I can build this amount in such
a small market I can build an absolute
for
I've got the whole if I've got the whole
country so I went there thinking without
a shadow of a doubt I will be earning an
absolute fortune mmm and to be honest
that that is kind of how it progressed
but being hit with the fact that it was
a recession construction being one of
the hardest hit markets during the
recession and and only specializing in
purlins I was well out of my depth
probably a good first it's probably
first sit three to six months drinking
all I've ever done is what I'm doing now
and it's not working there's no how do
how do I react so I started adding
elements in terms of doing freelance
because freelance was a bigger market
than perm so I had to get to grips with
a faster way of thinking yeah being an
explorer
I am spreadsheets have a process
procedure I am probably dull as
dishwater to most people because
everything's cut its place yeah and I've
followed the set process every week to
suddenly change from being permanent to
freelance difficult it's just miles
apart for me and my brain just doesn't
work quick enough yeah and if you're
going up against consultants that I've
done that for a couple of years anyway
they're already streets ahead of you
yeah so I kind of change tactic from the
freelance side but I also started
thinking okay walk within contractors
you've got everything from admin
receptionist pas right the way through
to back-office accounts HR and support
functions
so I started spreading my wings in terms
of the actual job roles that I was
dealing with in the construction market
I deal with especially somebody's right
the way through the main contractors
house builders developers it's quite a
wide market anyway but you were just
having to do over and above what the
expectation was to just even try and
find that baby hmm okay what just a
quick one because people always
interested I should have asked it
earlier but how how how did you do
billions wise at Hayes then like see
what what was this sort of caused you do
in the first year that you actually bill
really well in your first year oh yeah I
build to be honest I built throughout
reasonably well and my top perm you at
Hayes which is the record I was back
250-acre an ya best month was 17 perm
placements in a month it was a grand
that was the cause then it was only a
second year yeah
yeah that's awesome yeah I mean it was a
hard slog don't get me wrong and I put
everything into it but I was competing
against my wife not just at heist
I love that so what what was going
through my head when you're talking
about that and Steve what what did you
learn during that difficult period in
that recession that applies today I
think the biggest thing I learned was
that I was growing with my clients so I
would bring a construction contractor
who would say I've got no recruitment
this market has just stopped I'm not
even sure if my business is gonna be
there in two or three months why would I
need to speak to a consultant and which
are completely got I was that they're
equally thinking well I'm gonna be here
in two to three months either yeah so
you have to find that level of empathy
in that almost that sympathy in the fact
that we're all in this together hmm
no there's no way is certainly now even
more so now than ever before we are all
in the position where we've got to think
of new avenues to find income revenue
and build a business so during 2008 it
was talking to clients on the basis that
look I'm not gonna call you every Monday
in pitch a new candidate or something
you might need I will call you every
month and catch up and see where we are
and if there's a need then we can
discuss it but actually I want to build
a relationship where you call me when
you have a requirement and you know I
will do absolutely everything to make
sure that you get that person that you
need so you add real value and you don't
lose time and money wasting it going to
the whole market yeah I will add serious
value and I've always been about that
anyway I'm as I say borderline OCD very
honest very ethical very hardworking and
everything has a structure so every kind
knew if they gave me a role they would
get three to five people to say it would
be considered a choice the references
and all they the general stuff
consultants
we'll be done will be done yeah
and they got a good service and I didn't
run for the hills when he went wrong
either so if it was a bad placement or
the person didn't quite fit or whatever
it might be I always found a solution so
it was continually working towards that
value-added service one was one of the
things that did take and so how he's a
very good at KPI is they know the
numbers they know the ratios and I still
work to my targets that I had back in my
Hayes days okay but I almost fell to the
point that and I think the rest of the
industry has gone that way the KPI is
almost caged of consultant in and
everything's about whiteboard ticking
KPI ticking and it loses the element of
service delivery hmm and if anything
that the market is screaming at
recruitment agencies and consultants to
actually put service delivery at the top
of their list and actually fulfill the
service they're there to do
then call thousands of clients or not
for a service that they can't deliver on
mmm that's really interesting I mean it
came up again in the sort of live
podcast I did today but it's come up a
couple of times where a lot of people
have said that sort of you getting
through this particular period right now
will make you a better recruiter and I
think it's those types of things that
you're talking about that you going
through that Oh a period and really
recognizing and really hammering home
how important is building relationships
putting service at the top and being
empathetic same what you're gonna do
don't run when you need to be
responsible that sticks with you because
you know that that helps you through the
tough times
yeah you have to be accountable you have
to be responsible and for me the type of
consultants that I had between certainly
in the Birmingham office we had people
that genuinely cared about service and
the delivery and I've worked with
consultants and worked at places where
you do a handover because you're going
on the two-week holiday you get back at
that two-week holiday and yeah I left
messages go get all of them cool get all
them done nothing [ __ ] like that but
that's it's consistent in recruitment
because recruit many so selfish at times
mmm they'll sit there and
stay old Anacin think I'll just go
through it now where was I wanted I
wanted an environment where we're all
there heading in the right direction the
same direction and actually if one
consult was doing particularly well then
it goes across the whole office hmm
and we're all in it to make money so the
quicker we move to make money and bill
and place more the better the client
relationship the more chance they'll
give us other opportunities that fit in
other people's markets and debtors and I
think in many ways a lot of agencies
lose sight of that hmm and it's more
about the KPI bashing and the individual
than it is about the team and the brand
and everything pulling in the same
direction mmm definitely um how long how
long how long did that sort of period
going on for then did you say sort of
three six months I think my initial
struggle was about six months I think
building the relationships and getting
to a point where some momentum probably
took a good 12 months 12 months yeah
probably know what people want to hear
but it's not a short-term fix and nobody
at the moment he's thinking short term
especially you might yeah you might have
a bit on the freelance and you might
have some upside in some immediate roles
but actually recently see some clients
and they only more support than ever
from people that can deliver a service
so you've got to be there thinking long
term because you need them to be yeah
definitely okay so just to help me out
then I'll see you powered through that
got through that and then the gist was
the sort of growing of your team quiet
gradual or did it happen quite quickly
or in terms of yeah you bringing in
people that were aligned with the things
we were talking about yeah I mean we
should I grew it grew over an 11-year
period yeah
Manchester Road in 2015 was probably one
of the most difficult tasks I did
because I wasn't so familiar with the
area
yeah so where is our new consultants in
the West Midlands and I knew their
backgrounds and whether they're any good
or not and Manchester has to be
different so I suppose over the years I
found myself going forward a few steps
and going back a few and I got to a
point towards the end certainly in
recruitment why
I wanted to kind of give consultants a
little bit of a hard time that interview
in the fact that I wanted to understand
their motivations and their reasons why
they're doing it to the point where I
know whatever is thrown at them they
will rise above it get past it
as long as that by the way for me its
top of the list really it is top of the
list I would rather take someone with no
experience that has an unwavering
determination to be successful than
someone with 10 15 years experience raft
of Billings behind them but actually
they're probably more Maverick than they
are team player mmm I would go for the
determine why the ones motivated to do
well because they have a reason whether
that's your wedding and buy their first
house they want the flash holidays and
their nice clothes or whatever it might
be I want to get I want them to get me
to a point where I think if I would be
crazy not to offer them a job mmm
because of their pure determination and
motivation to succeed and then someone
that actually is just moving about
because they want a bit more on their
salary and then ok Billy because they
just do enough to get by I think I think
even in like challenging times right now
that's what's gonna keep you going as
well I think part of what your mum yeah
my personal belief recruitment is
difficult anyway Monday to Friday it's
listening objections listen with things
that go wrong and generally it's the
tough that survive but actually in this
current market it will be the tougher
the still survive music so to get that
vacancy to get that role to get to the
placement the competition is going to be
fierce
mmm and actually knowing why you're
doing it he's gonna exactly that and I
think it will fall back again to the
relationships with the client and the
candidate I've got clients that I know
will only use me mmm I've got clients
that certainly last year I was the top
performing consulting on that PSL and I
wasn't on the PSL
because because the clients will want to
use me regardless of what companies were
added to their supply chain because they
know what they get yeah and I think I
think having that established
relationship will certainly help a lot
of individuals hmm
so I know it's a quite a long period but
sort of thinking about you then powering
on to the point where you're looking at
obviously starting the Manchester office
did you continue to bring the Tipsy
bring and achieve that success that you
got early on that Hayes fast track as
you was building the team and for me
personally yeah for you pal I mean what
my Billings took a hit and but I was
still billing at the top level of Perm
Billings within the company and
certainly for the first good number of
years I was at the top of the
leaderboard alongside one of the base
down in the Watford otters mmm enjoy the
buzz and and my whole ethos was how can
I expect any consultants that I'm
managing or mentoring to respect Who I
am and want to improve if I'm at the
bottom of their thinking
I guess what they yeah what I was going
to say they don't a lot of exert Lee the
guys out of Birmingham hadn't worked
with me at Hayes so they wouldn't have
seen me they wouldn't have seen the one
that was lauded up on stage that's just
me
yeah yeah you have to do it from the
front you have to meet them that's what
you want everyone to follow you in that
journey yeah III get that I guess what
I'd really like to sort of an dive into
van why I ask that is two things one
sort of thing just uncovering a bit
around sort of how Steve the the biller
that always wants to be at the top how
are you sort of broke through those
glass ceilings mm-hmm and then the
second thing that I really want to dive
into is that experience you're talking
about in terms of managing and being a
biller and sort of dealing with that I
guess push and pull of wanted to be the
Bill of having the high expectations but
then it's other people you can't expect
them to be the Steve guests or whatever
yeah there's I know a lot of people
shrug with that
speak a lot about that on here so I
guess the first thing like a really
common question and things that people
really interested in is finding out from
people like you on like how how does a
sort of BAE for Steve look like when
you're someone that's been in 250k plus
or what what is a bill is they actually
look like what they're doing differently
how can I break like the real common one
I always get hisham I've hit the hundred
eighty came out for the last two years
I just can't break this 200k Billings
mark what does the typical day look like
and what are they what are people doing
differently there are over that terms
okay to go I mean I think obviously
every marketing sector and individuals
going to be different but for me it was
I was an absolute grafter and and I've
always valued my time completely as my
time so little things that I would get
the office to work to as well with your
non mean your tasks you shouldn't be in
a position where you're answering those
where you're trying to make sales so you
shouldn't be picking the phone up
perhaps between like 9:00 and 12:00 and
2:00 and 5:00
you should be only dialing out okay so
things like people ringing in about and
the areas of are done have you got my
time machine all these questions that
need to be answered should be done by
support staff within the office so
simple things like that
I had a consultant in Manchester great
guy good consultant he was sat with me
saying how do I become that next level
up and it's almost like that marginal
gain kind of conversation day browse for
the British Cycling Team being creative
about the small elements that you can
change on your day yes so he used to
come in at 8 o'clock
abby's bowl of cereal just cup of coffee
you would be on the Nile at half eight
start making schools so I said to him
just a sympathy construction starts at
heart seven it's great that you come in
at 8:00 to hardly get yourself sorted
and you set for your day but why are you
doing that and he said well that's
that's what's in my contract okay okay
that's great I'm not
telling you any different if that's
weird it's fine but if I was competing
against you I would be in at seven
I'd have my breakfast my cereal my
coffee I would start work at half seven
and I'm an hour ahead of you already I
already sent the Stephens that you
haven't looked at yet and I might take
an extra half an hour at lunch because I
was in earlier not that I would have
done but that gives you it gives you the
idea that you sit there anything so
another example if I've got a really
good candidate that comes in the general
mold of working is you speak to 30
clients about that candidate that are
suitable for that person's skill set
that's how I would set up a candidate
I'd send out a marketing email and I
would perhaps put something out on
social media for me the best thing to do
is to send that a marketing email first
to everybody that you was in with that
is within your market and then make your
30 calls because you might have 600
other contractors then all thinking oh
I'm supposed to state before you've got
a really good candidate to get your
market to come to you as much as your
outsourced sorry
selling the candidate out does that make
sense jerem isn't it it's about being as
creative as possible as quickly as
possible so you have all the elements
working in your favor post on LinkedIn
I've got this great candidate does this
an email market goes out saying I've got
this great candidate then you get on the
phone and you make your 30 calls as you
think's working in conjunction with each
other and it means you're moving faster
than your competitor who might just sit
there thinking I've gotta make more
calls on this candidate now hmm so they
start planning through the course
marginal gains is big its marginal gains
even massive and I think for me there's
a whole book there for me so again my
list because just going through the
simplest little bits asking every
candidate you speak to for three
referrals or people looking to work
being systematic in your approach and
doing everything in a process means
you're so well coordinated and
everything fits in into place
hmm I have the same process regardless
of vacancy candidate level geographical
area
don't change yeah what what does it just
quickly cuz loads of people ways
interesting it's like what did your
typical day look like Steve like when he
was at your peak I would be sitting and
planning up my day generally I'll have
made I don't know 10 15 calls before
anyone's even surfaced and then it's
about making sure you've got call list
in your car you've got to do list if you
drive into a meeting I used to get I've
still do now I'll get to any meetings
half an hour early always have done
that's again a bit OCD in a bit strange
the pet doesn't matter where the meeting
is I'm still having but I'll always have
things in the car that I can sit there
and I get things done and I'm not
stressing about being late for a meeting
because I'm already there mmm I would
always be the last to leave I take my
work home take it on holiday then wife's
never been too happy with that but if I
can make placements within a couple of
calls it's about living and breathing it
so much so that you you just out class
or you can pass this is chief in people
willing to do that now yeah I think so
I think you just have to you have to do
with a slight difference in your sales
pitch mmm
am I so am I still willing to do no no
the reason why I ask is because the way
I'd like if I think of all the people
that I've sat down with and sort of
speaking about and uncovering sort of
what what makes a top billets not Billa
right in line with your book the FIR the
first thing and then is what we talk
about as work ethic so I guess I think
in and I always speak about this in the
world of work-life balance in in the
world of mental health these types of
things just because you do all that
doesn't mean that you're gonna have
struggled dealing with it mentally
whatever you're clearly you'll clearly
someone that wants to be the best and
they're the sort of standards that you
have for yourself but I guess you speak
to a lot of concerns now how many how
many people are willing to do that
that's not mean or mean yeah I mean how
many people willing to do that anymore
because it's it's back to what you said
[ __ ] off Steve that's not my contract
- I mean so I guess I think that's what
is interesting Mike because I think one
a lot of people were looking for well
Steve said that if I instead of having
my coffee at 8:30 a that means I could
make five more calls which means I could
potentially make five more grand people
are looking for that rather than you
rather than here and you going well
actually you've got grass yeah a great
book called the compound effect by
Darren Hardy yeah yeah again going back
towards marginal gains and things so if
I'm targeting a consultant to do 20
sales calls a day which is more than
achievable my expectation and the way I
would like people to think as a
consultant will be actually Steve I'll
do 20 but I'm gonna do 21 it's one extra
call but that one extra call over a year
makes two weeks worth of extra acting
which is crazy so I think people think
to short-term they get put off by the
fact actually you've got a work bloody
hard to be any good at this and you've
got to if you've got to get to seven
touch points with a client for them to
having confidence in you as a person
you've got to get set six seven months
into a role before actually you've built
the desk anyway that's a hell of a lot
of rejection in that time to have an
unwavering determination to be
successful in improvement to get past
all of that and then still continue to
want to do it 14 years and recruitments
quite a long time these days yeah and
you've still got to get up every day
skip into work and think this is where I
want to be yeah if you don't have that
and you don't have the willingness to
completely change the rulebook and
create your own targets and motivations
the the recruiting stream will eat you
alive yeah definitely so what did what
did Steve the manager there like then
how did you because I feel like I think
this has come up a lot where the sort of
hard learnings as a manager or billing
manager is that though those standards
that you have for yourself there you
can't impose those and expect those of
yeah like team member one together I'm
here that's the quickest way to go to
get yeah to obviously get frustrated is
now for you
can't think that way so I guess what
what was your experience like or subtle
key learnings in just getting better at
being the manager yeah I loved being a
manager and I love my team
100% loyal to every single person I
recruited across Birmingham Manchester
they were all really hard genuine honest
grafting consultants they knew their
markets and as I say it was bad service
delivery side of things I wanted every
single consultant that I've ever managed
to do and overachieve on everything they
ever were given today
part of my belief there is if they are
doing really well the office will be
doing really well I would look really
good and I'll be able to go in front of
the directors and say look how good this
person's done this person's done there
over excel in the office is headed in
the right direction we're a great team
look look at us all and we all benefit
and that was always my view I would
always protect consultants from negative
or bad comments from board meetings for
director meetings in the fact that I
wanted to manage them in a way that was
empowering and motivating for that I
think in the first view that few years
of management this big learning curve
because I suppose I would treat everyone
the same way and then over time you get
to know that actually shouting at
someone and being extremely direct will
work some people will get offended and
not have an impact in there whereas
others if actually you just find a way
to motivate them or incentivize them
they would just pick their game up
anyway yeah and I think it was a you you
gain the knack of I suppose learning
characteristics of people and learning
the touch points in terms of what makes
or what creates a reaction but I've
always been a very considered person I'm
never the loud one I'm never the one
that's in a meeting that will be
shouting out the answers or standing up
that making a big statement
I'm the considered calm one that makes
stupid amounts of notes will go away
have considered answers and it might
save you two days to come back to
an answer but it will be well thought
out it will be practical and it will be
constructive and that's how my
management has been so if things weren't
working and people were underperforming
there would be practical ways to make
sure that improves my feedback from my
management style couple years ago was it
if I had a weakness it was the fact that
I believed consultants could get there
probably more so than they did so yeah
nothing for them because my my sense of
belief is anybody can do it if they set
their heart on it and they work hard
enough and they do all the bits around
it to make it work yeah but actually I
think sometimes I believed or wanted
them to do it more so than they did them
the that's really interesting and the
comments back where sometimes you're
probably too nice to people to you give
them too much leeway where was actually
you should have been a bit more
cutthroat and said quite quickly you're
never gonna make this because you don't
do this this this and this yeah that's
interesting so let's talk about I love
when you said you or someone it's
considered that definitely doesn't speak
to you in the way that you're answering
the questions that that's definitely
case and I think that's great
self-awareness to know that and that's
awesome so I guess well what I'd love to
just talk about Steve is is definitely
why you've decided to write the book
I mean clearly someone's passionate
about recruitment been in it for over a
decade and again really set yourself
high standards and have always tried to
be the best so I guess where well is the
motivation to write the book I think
there's two there's two reasons the
motivation comes from the circles that
are mixed with I mixed with a lot of
entrepreneurial type people I've got
mentors in various parts of my life
outside of recruitment and I read a lot
anyway probably two or three books a
month okay and they all say obviously
everyone's got a book in them and I was
sat there thinking I'm not your typical
recruiter yeah I am I'm not the latest
I'm not the salesperson and wasn't too
startling so I wanted to write something
but actually said if you a methodical
process procedure and
actually you just delivered on what you
say you're gonna do mmm you can still be
really successful in recruitment and you
don't need to be the loud one the second
part of the book was I kind of knew my
my time with working with fast chapters
was coming towards an end and I wanted
to go off on a different path so I
wanted to write the book to create a
differentiator for me and to build my
own personal brand on the basis that the
book was never to be a profitable asset
for me it was more of a business card
and and I'm I was writing the book so to
write the book to give you some idea I
was getting up at 5 o'clock I was
getting into the office for half I'd I
would write an hour of the book between
r5 and r6 before I then set up my day
before the consultants came well so that
book took serious graft and not a lot of
sleep and I would the pure reason for
doing it was to motivate consultants
that need a bit of motivation or some
help with some supporting structure
which a lot of people I work with often
lack because they look the sales a bit
they don't know the process but also I
wanted to elevate me up to a different
level for when I went too early on my
own because I felt like I needed that
impact to actually just say it's just me
now hmm intestine it's it's been a
really humbling journey to be honest
yeah so see what what you've been and
sort of talk to the president now
obviously what what you've been doing
this week is and have been spending a
lot time with consultants and speaking
to them and offering her advice given
value which which I think's awesome I
think sort of the the sort of journey
that this podcast has been on I've been
on and I don't know a few experiences
when you start to look at a book or
think about a book but when I started in
McCrimmon bigger than 2016 I went into
that sort of recruitment I went into
recruitment having the mindset of begins
my personal development I was really
open to learning from other people
always reading books that always said if
you want to get to point A find someone
that's got to point a and learn from
them how they did that blah blah blah
right so when I entered the world of
recruitment obviously when you're in a
small recruitment business which the
majority of the market is made up of
obviously you as already said it you're
oh you only have access to the four
people in your four walls yeah though
when I learnt from these great people
around me and I wanted to be creative
innovative with how I could approach
things bla bla bla there's certain
pockets of sort of knowledge or things
that I was hungry for that the people
around me didn't have yes oh but and
then when you go in this sort of journey
to find out about recruitment which I
did before I enter the industry because
I wanted to get into it and I read the
rich Prakriti book and I I googled all
these things there was really and then
when one then when I wanted to sort of
trying up my game as a recruiter there
was limited content that there really
was and I think what's been really
interested people like you the podcast
and so much more going on right now is
that people really are open to help
other people and learn from people like
you and you know sorts of things and I
think I think that's that's great cuz I
think I'm sure you I hope for you'd
agree there may be when you started in
hazing these types of things to speed up
recruit ism hasty how you
how'd you do this well how do you
structure a day people would have
probably been my [ __ ] off do that do you
not I mean so yeah I think that's that's
awesome and I think to like when you
looked up shall I do a book like there
isn't much out there there is there is
not when I did my kind of research what
I came up with really was that there are
recruitment books sure but a lot of them
are more like text books and they're
written by coaches trained yeah people
that haven't recruited for five or ten
years exact and whilst they follow the
set process and they cover everything
you need I stopped reading most of them
because you sat there thinking oh god
it's just going through what you do
anyway I know I wanted to write
something that was relatable and
actually showed the highs and lows
people can connect with and think you
know what I have really bad days like
that
I have excuses like that when people
don't turn up and but actually there's a
few things in there that so Steve does
differently
I can implement that and I can add some
add some value and ultimately Mike
honest
enough from the book the initial
planners assay was six months recruiting
potentially opening a new recruitment
business and then building that but
actually I was looking and what I've
missed most last four or five months
he's training and mentoring and working
with consultants and and over the past
few weeks as you say this week I've
given up all my free time this week to
speak to consultants they're half an
hour slots and there's my initial
thought process well as I'd get 15 to 20
calls over a week and I'm actually
getting probably 10 to 15 a day that's
awesome
and I am stacked a Monday to Friday and
I'm loving every minute of it
because I feel like and I can give some
value and content back to people that
actually have that want improve exactly
yeah if they're booking into a diary
then they're the type of people that you
want a fantastic yeah well and so let's
sorry so it's about in there but I guess
what I'd love to just get your thoughts
on is what are the common things that
you're saying what a common sort of
you're seeing in recruiters of today
that are sort of preventing them they're
going to Steve I'm struggling with this
or Steve on and get here and I'm finding
it hard like what are the common from
your perspective as you've been doing
this and digging deep here people the
common thread is people are struggling
with just creating a personal brand that
seems to be the top of the list okay I
think it's really simple things like
people don't want to do a social media
video why do you fit what so we'll see
on my business now is helping recruit it
build their personal brands right yeah
why is this become so important in your
opinion I don't know sort of impose my
opinion but like you here in this we
just said that my view is the current
market so for me construction is not
moving there's no permanent requirements
and no matter how hard I try or home
hi-de-ho call people the general answer
is going to be no we've got no
requirements yeah so if I'm sat at home
if I'm on furlough or my market isn't
moving but I've got some income and I
need to be doing something
social media and and putting your
personal brand and creating videos to
show that you're relevant in the market
you're an honest hard-working ethical
genuine person that is passionate about
what they do the only way you are going
to get that across is either calling
your clients on zoom' calls to talk to
them about a market that stopped or
putting your content onto social media
that people can freely look at and
understand so you explain who you are as
a person what your core values are what
motivates you when you've had a bad day
when you've had a good day people start
buying into you as an individual so the
market starts picking up and I've been
to networking events where I have people
come up to me and feel like they already
know me I've never met them but because
my social media is relatively strong
people live the day-to-day journey with
you know cause and when I was doing took
me 12 months to do my first 2018 and
then I was challenged to do 10 videos in
10 days which I did I loved every minute
of it it was all about self-development
my own motivation and everything else
but I had consultants going on client
meetings talking about me and my videos
and it was really irritating them
because they were like I've gone to that
meeting why are they talking about you
yeah and if that point doesn't drive
home how important it is to just be out
there it allows people to watch you even
if they don't like comment or engage it
allows people to make an assessment as
to you whether you are someone they want
to work with and if they then start
contacting you you don't have to pitch
the sale mmm you're right I think yeah
like like just interesting they're not
keen to tell my two Pence's but what do
you think recruiters already have a
personal brand it depends where they
work okay because I just think it's
really interesting that you're sort of
top of the list is that people wanna
don't have to start building personal
brand then what about I'm just I was I
wasn't expecting that I feel he's gonna
say about but then I break in certain
bidding glass ceilings or yeah I mean
don't get me wrong that's got to be
there
but I take that as a given anyway mmm
sure because I would expect if you do in
this you want to be at the top and you
want to be the best but in a market
where everything has kind of halted mmm
familiy given today the best thing
people can be doing is staying within
their market letting clients candidates
know that you're you're still busy
you're there to be spoken to people
wanna have a chat you irrelevant you're
consistent and you constantly reminding
your market that you're there if you're
a consultant that's I don't know you've
been told you don't to come back in to
work till June you just need to sit at
home if that was me I couldn't sit still
anyway no I couldn't earn but if you are
just sat there people will go past you
because they'll have built a brand and
people remembering and have lived that
journey through what is a tough time and
they'll go to those people guarantee
what what's the common what's the common
challenge then if people send Steve LOD
I'd love what you didn't on LinkedIn
like how can I start doing that for
myself water so you mentioned about
obviously people are worried about
sharing videos and I'd said you resonate
with that and I'll see I was worried
about sharing videos when when I was in
recruitment but like from your
perspective and what was the common
thing that you hear in there because
that might be useful for people listen
to the ISIS confidence purely yeah he's
confidence and it's the fact that you
open yourself to ridicule and critique
and that is constant that is that is the
message it was the same when I published
the book that week running up to it
being published I was it could have all
fell apart people could have said it's
the worst written on it you write my
first ever social media video was hi
this is Steve this is my first ever
social media video there's no value
there's no content I'm not even gonna
say next
I just got over 12 months of
procrastination here it is hope you
enjoy it I think it was something along
them lines that was it yeah and then to
do the next ten because I then had to do
the ten it gets you over that hurdle of
what am I gonna say what if I'm muck up
you just you just got to put it out
there I think once you've done one and
you've got the ability to think I've
just got to think of some sort of
content every day to keep it moving the
amount of exposure I got from videos far
outweighs anything I've done I was
getting four five six clients that I
hadn't spoken to her for years and years
every day email me to say what's your
video on tomorrow
loving the video content and I'm
appreciate women spoke for ages but it's
probably worth it a catch-up hmm what's
your view love awesome mate what and I
love getting your perspective on this
because these obviously the things that
I talk about a lot so I guess and then
the sort of other things has tie this
together which i think is really
interested in what so what's your view
on then like for you is it is it
personal brand versus quite and quite
old-school methods or like gin I mean
you said there that it's drive because a
lot of people the the sort of skeptics
are okay Steve great that you're doing
videos but how that's how is that making
your money mate I'd rather make ya
business Veneman calls right so I guess
what's your view on and you've been in
the game for a while right and you know
you've got a lovely process you know
that you need to do you know the outputs
you need to do and I'm kind of a
southern male from 2018 you been in
Creighton content videos blah blah blah
like what's your view on sort of yeah
the personal brand new methods if you
want to call it that yeah hey you've
known for me it's complimentary you know
he's in addition to so you cannot get
past the fact that you still got to do
the activity yeah i've what i've worked
with consultants that believe because we
know the digital age in social media
driven actually they can send a hundred
messages through linkedin and that means
they don't have to make any calls but
actually their messages on linkedin
Okies crap the open rate is crap yeah
and they never get to ask any other
questions and what was in the email that
didn't get read we just got a letter
because it was a pitch so you have to
combine everything in there and for me I
just work on a couple of posts every day
Monday to Friday that are relevant to
what I do and they back up Who I am and
how I work that allows the people that
don't pick up the phone don't respond to
an email and haven't necessarily ever
wanted to work with me but actually they
get to know me a bit better
from being the quiet observance in the
background for her and then in six
months time they may well pick up the
phone mmm
there's so many things I have I declined
that never answered the phone to me I
used to drop into reception on the whim
that they might come out and come and
speak to me nothing no replies to email
nothing on the phone I sent them a
handwritten letter after eight years of
trying and they responded and they're
now good key client love that most
people would have given up after I died
four months but eight years I was
repeated emailing this client and then
he finally responded to a handwritten
lesson and now it's called Snee mails
and everything's fine I think um I love
that story I think with what you said I
think that that's also the opportunity
that there will be a lot of your
competitors that are that have got
complacent with ah well I've sent for
email so they Steve I've done my source
in or yeah and and I think that's for me
I'm huge on this is about nice then I
will face them complicit or day long
yeah exactly but you're right about
combining the both that's the
opportunity well yeah like now there's
even more of an opportunity to get
access to people speak to people and it
is about combining the both I think what
just my depends on what you said which i
think is is gray is that this whole
content pieces just enable you to have
more opportunities to speak to people
and for me that that's that's why I
started creating content in when I was
in recruitment because I I just needed
to get five ten more opportunities to
say to people hey my nation when this is
how I'm different and when you share
content and it enables you to have sort
of touch points with people in your
market that may not that aren't onto the
emails that I'm picking up your phone
but all of a sudden they get to the
experience or have a bit of an
understanding of who you are what you're
about and then there may be open to
actually having a conversation or at
least finding out who you are yeah that
that's everything about today about
being creative so in my LinkedIn Network
I might have people that I don't know
I've never spoken to and they purely
just watch what I put on my feet yeah I
don't know who they're associated with
so I sit there creating contact
they look at never comment never say
anything but actually their husband or
wife is the MD or the CEO of one of the
biggest companies I might want to
recruit for and it's just having the
ability to allow a market to work for
you without you having to necessarily do
or contact every single person on the
planet so in regards to the the but then
Steve if if people were to read it and
sort of they were to and they were to
take and action
like one piece of advice from the book
or like you would want them to like make
sure that there's one piece of advice or
two pieces of advice that they that
really gets through to them in the
action what would those things be for me
the whole book is about structure so
it's about how do I know that doesn't
surprise me Steve you're gonna get
somewhere by actually not knowing where
you're headed mmm so get you structure
get your plan whether that's an hourly
daily weekly monthly plan and have it
placed so that there is a process to
follow you follow the process things
will happen yeah so that it really is
that the the process the structure
that's interesting I say that most
people are turning off now because all
process instructor I've proved it works
and if you ever sat there thinking I
don't even know how many calls I've made
today but I've had a really busy day
the chances are actually you've just
been on someone else's agenda you've
probably answered the phone loads of
times and passed there's other people
and that in terms of your selfish
Billings in your personal desk you've
probably done three outgoing calls that
is in my experience people don't
understand that a busy day is necessary
profitable yeah you know well that's
really interesting so it's a bit is it
is it that then the lot of people just
fall short on them like just really not
actually understanding what a good day
looks like yeah it's not having order
and not knowing what they're trying to
get out of the day mmm I think a lot of
people I know what they need to do to
make that day oh yeah their box ticking
hmm and I think it's because the KPI
part is so heavily driven that you end
up making calls for calls sake because
you need to tick the box yeah
actually if you had if I told you 20 we
did 15 quality calls 15 to 5 I got no
problems with it's only a framework but
ultimately you don't want to be just
ticking the boxes for the sake of it you
need to structure in the process behind
why you're trying to do yeah and I think
more often than not the why isn't
explained well enough it's just the
amount of consultants to get there yeah
so it's it really is back to basics oh
yeah what as part of that is that you're
preaching these people and and you
really believe that sort of getting a
grip of that and really understanding
that structure process you know enable
those that are at any level I guess what
light maybe found themselves getting a
bit comfortable complacent or got used
to Billy on X amount of money you think
there's there's opportunities there if
they really think about that hardly I
don't often be practical and take action
they can really impact like increase
their yeah if you're a 150 180 K Billa
and you've been consistent for three or
four years the best thing you can do
there is look at how you work yeah and
look at the marginal gains again and
where you can make improvements or
change slightly yeah if you haven't got
a structure in a process how are you
gonna make your module game you've got
no way to quantify any of it so you
can't improve or assess anything because
you just work the way you work mmm and
and is when you say structure is it like
are we talking like okay so okay Steve
well look this is my structure from 10
to 12 every Tuesday and Thursday I do my
business development and that's me
trying to obviously contacts and speak
to new clients and then of every
everyday - till 5:00 I'm spending
sourcing jobs that I've got exclusive or
and a sort of high priority that I know
I can make placements out of like is
this what we're talking is
structure-wise
yeah I mean for me it has to be more
defined but yeah I mean my that is a
similar sort of thing so I say I can go
into I don't mean you've got that much
time but my structure is the same no
let's talk about because I think a lot
of people will that people on a nice
team what the [ __ ] is a day look like
mate
bestir my KPI is that I worked
throughout haze that I still work to
today it's roughly defined as 20 sales
calls a day to decision-makers three
client meetings a week five candidate
meetings a week ten interviews to be
arranged a week to e shots a week to
mailers a week and then the bolt on to
that is I will pick two vacancies to go
into any week to specialize in and on so
over those two two vacancies I want to
speak to thirty specific candidates for
each vacancy I want an e shot to go out
and I want some social media marketing
on on each Fagan six same in the
candidates candidates have thirty points
of contact for each individual looking
for a new role candidates spec an email
a social media spec well it will be
sectioned into core areas so between
nine and twelve is sales calls to till
five sales calls areas in between his
admin and advert what else is this I
will send an asset register once a month
which I talk about in my book an asset
register is a collection of the
candidates and a vague description in
terms of their characteristics I'll send
that adds up the whole market that I
recruit for what that enables means
other clients within the company you
don't know we don't necessarily speak to
have the option for one of their
internal staff to forward it on to them
opens up your market creates momentum it
enables you to if you're feeling a bit
crappy and you've had a rubbish week
send the asset register out because it
automatically engages most of your
market if you've got that relationship
built up I do too social media posted on
LinkedIn on at breakfast one at lunch
because it's the most engaged times and
people looking on LinkedIn as far as
I've made it out and then it's about
doing anything over and above those
actions all the targets that I've said
they're always naturally try and beat by
one or two bringing in the compound
effect and everything else that goes
with how did you keep track of all that
me I can imagine but listen again Stevie
just I'll just lost you
now obviously the photo all I want to
say firstly is I love that I think
that's what that definitely me
personally since start my own business
I've had to get better at sort of strut
structure my weeks specific days and
when I've actually so what I very
quickly realized is that when I started
my business I was basically just I would
do obviously my utmost to sell to
clients get new clients obviously paying
and then I would fit them into the diary
that I had right and I don't see here a
lot at the time like don't was it don't
let clients dictate sort of you in your
time right yeah though but what I
realized was I had what I was doing was
I had no structure to put my clients in
I mean so I was just like I was just
calling people I was actually closing
people and then but right okay let me
look at my Darwin can I start fit you in
I had no strikes department so like yeah
I love you Whaley
you've got to value it the consultants
that work with me got to know that if
they walked up to my desk between sales
hours I would not speak to them I pretty
much just put my hand up and they're
gonna sit back down and what he seems a
bit rude at the start and they're like I
need to ask this question you'd be like
well can it wait till lunchtime or easy
urgent now if it's urgent obviously Yelp
more often than not value your time but
if you're walking around the office
trying to find some menial or admin
question and actually it doesn't support
what you're there to do yeah save it for
a time where you've got the time to do
yeah I go into each day so I always get
to the office an area and to plan what
I'm doing to the day and and it's also
to have a bit of peace and quiet to be
honest and a quite costly on my own it
allows me to set it up so I will have
goals that I'm looking to achieve for
the day and I'll have aged B's and C's
azar I can't get through the day without
having achieved yeah babies are okay but
I really need to get them done and C's
can wait till tomorrow if I don't get
these nails done and I've created them
what I call the month planner so that's
a collection of my habits over 14 years
and it's a basic day plan week grand
month plan all in a booklet I have been
female inmates and consultants because I
think there's a lot of people at the
moment that's at home and how you feel
trekking it so it's a button but that
was gonna be my question that how did
you actually get back yeah yeah yeah and
even naughty spreadsheet if you aren't
even counting the amount of calls you're
making yeah how do you know if you're
being busy so I have you tick off the
number if you have a good morning you
get to lunch and you look at the fact
you've done ten calls in the morning
yeah that's an okay morning if you get
to lunch and you've made three you've
got one hell of an afternoon coming up
yeah and you've got to be able to go off
for lunch have a water and block eat
your sandwich and think you know what
nothing is gonna stop me this afternoon
because I've gotta go and find someone I
love that that's so good that went on a
bit of a tangent there but I'm glad we
did because I think like we spoke you
spoke a lot about structure and process
nothing we finally got into the Steve
secret sauce if any of the listeners
want the month planner I've been
emailing the mage so cool just drop a
note yeah I mean so contact me I guess
yeah as we sort of come come to the
close here Steve I guess yeah a couple
of things so firstly see you're you're
clearly someone that's willing to help
give back so anyone that's listening
that as in sort of really been
interested how Steve's been articulating
what makes a good bill Oh common things
that you've been seeing the process and
habits that you formed then obviously
were happy for these people to reach out
and yeah of course
and yeah I guess obviously what we will
be doing also I want to help you as much
as possible
so I guess as we sort of agree before we
started this obviously when when you
post about being on the podcast and when
we release this I think we agreed in
reader basically if anyone hopes that
people that listen to this if they
comment on the Steve's post and you see
it when we announce this what we want
you to do is is comment on Steve's post
saying sort of what your key learning
was or key takeaway was from the episode
and you commenting once these posts will
mean that
you get sort of put into a hat that
means that you can win a free book of
the free table but basically you're
gonna give a couple of copy of those
away for people yeah awesome so we'll
make that clearer again when we post
about it but wanting to make that make
everyone aware that if you've got to
this part of the episode that you can do
that to make sure that you do so we're
always like to sort of finish this
episode Steve ISM well firstly what what
you what I saw sounds a bit weird asking
it and I always ask it but with what's
going on but like what you excited about
for me I've really enjoyed getting back
into the mentoring the training
consulting so I think that's that's
going to be a new avenue that I'll be
pursuing I've already got a few clients
and potential consultants that want me
to help mentor them which is great I'm
currently developing an app called the
expert recruiter amazing which will be a
central place a centralized place for
people to go and get value and content
and which I'm really excited about lots
of work to be done to be fair yeah for
me I mean you're not meant to say things
that you find opportunity in down times
but through these there you just got to
go and get it and it does excite me to
be honest I love that I think that's
great what you're doing so question
always ask if Steve could communicate to
every single recruiter out there they'd
listen and take on an advice it could be
a phrase of words a sentence but they
would take one advice a action it they'd
implement it tomorrow what would you say
to the people I suppose something that
I've always worked to is just deliver on
what you say you're gonna do yeah goes a
long way it isn't that I'm recruitment
it's full of people that blank it and
they will tell someone or oversell and
it just don't deliver yeah and that is
probably a common thread
full of free people makes it you do what
you're gonna say what you say that
you're going to do and but it's they've
really enjoyed that thank you so much
for your time I think a lot of the
listeners will get a lot of value out of
them this conversation so just a big
fans really love what you do and
pleasure and thanks a lot thank you